Der Erfolg unseres VQE-Algorithmus hängt stark
vom Zustand und circuit ab,
mit dem wir beginnen.
Ich bin Victoria Lipinska und in diesem Video
erkunden wir die Möglichkeiten,
die wir bei deren Gestaltung haben.
Schauen wir uns
alle Elemente genauer an,
die wir in jedem Durchlauf des Quantenteils
des VQE haben.
Wir beginnen mit dem Referenzzustand,
der manchmal auch Anfangszustand genannt wird.
Wir führen den Referenzzustand
durch einen parametrisierten circuit, den man
Variationsform nennt,
mit einer anfänglichen Parameterwahl.
Dann messen wir den Zustand
in der Basis des Hamiltonians,
nachdem wir ihn durch den circuit geführt haben,
um den Erwartungswert zu erhalten. Nun
gehen wir jeden dieser Elemente durch,
beginnend mit dem Referenzzustand.
Eine typische Wahl für den Referenzzustand
ist der Nullzustand.
Das ist der Zustand, in dem ein Quantencomputer
bereits initialisiert ist.
Für Quantenchemie-Probleme
kann man auch den sogenannten
Hartree-Fock-Zustand verwenden,
der das Ergebnis einer Hartree-Fock-Methode
ist.
Kurz gesagt bietet die Hartree-Fock-Theorie
eine einfache Möglichkeit,
den Referenzzustand zu konstruieren, indem
der Grundzustand eines Quantensystems approximiert wird.
Sie findet eine Rotation
innerhalb des Zustandsraums,
die die Grundzustandsenergie minimiert.
Schließlich kann der Referenzzustand
auch sehr problemspezifisch sein,
und du möchtest vielleicht einen
benutzerdefinierten Zustand wählen.
Wenn du weißt, welche Eigenschaften
dein System hat, zum Beispiel Symmetrien,
oder eine bestimmte Anzahl von Elektronen
im Zustand, kannst du das nutzen,
um eine bessere Konvergenz des VQE-Algorithmus
zu erzielen.
Die Wahl eines guten Referenzzustands
ist wichtig für die Konvergenz.
Referenzzustände, die nahe am
Grundzustand liegen,
können dafür sorgen, dass das Problem
viel einfacher und schneller konvergiert.
Ähnlich wichtig
ist die Wahl der anfänglichen Parameterwerte,
die wir in die Variationsform einspeisen.
Daher kann es je nach Referenzzustand
und Anfangsparametern
zu schneller, langsamer oder
gar keiner Konvergenz kommen.
Schauen wir uns diesen Plot an
und stellen wir uns zur Veranschaulichung vor,
dass unser Parameterraum
nur einen Parameter hat.
Ein sehr guter Referenzzustand
kann es dir erlauben, sehr nah
am endgültigen Grundzustand zu starten,
sodass die Konvergenz schnell ist.
Wenn du andererseits sehr weit
vom Grundzustand entfernt startest,
Referenzzustand a,
musst du eine hohe Energiebarriere überwinden,
was zu einer sehr langsamen Konvergenz
oder gar keiner Konvergenz führt.
Das werden wir ausführlicher im Modul
zur klassischen Optimierung besprechen,
das zu diesem Kurs gehört.
Schauen wir uns jetzt den parametrisierten circuit an,
der auf den Referenzzustand wirkt, auch bekannt als
die Variationsform.
Wenn dieser circuit, U von theta, auf den Referenz-
zustand wirkt,
erzeugt er das, was wir Probezustand nennen.
Psi von theta, oder manchmal ansatz.
Dieser ansatz-Zustand wird dann
in einer geeigneten Basis gemessen,
um den Erwartungswert
für die Energie zu erhalten.
Die Variationsformen,
die wir hier besprechen,
sind durch die Chemie motiviert.
Behalte aber im Hinterkopf,
dass es auch solche gibt, die von
Quantenmaschinellem Lernen
und anderen kurzfristigen
Algorithmen wie dem Quantum
Approximate Optimization Algorithm inspiriert sind.
Lass uns einige gängige Wahlmöglichkeiten
für einen chemischen ansatz besprechen.
Unitary Coupled Cluster oder UCC
ist die Methode, die ursprünglich
in der ersten VQE-Veröffentlichung vorgeschlagen wurde,
und sie wird häufig in der
Quantenchemie eingesetzt.
Wenn wir einen Quantenzustand
parametrisieren,
arbeiten wir typischerweise mit
exponentiell vielen Parametern.
Um die Vorbereitungs-circuits jedoch
effizient zu machen,
brauchen wir eine polynomielle Anzahl
von Operationen
und daher eine polynomielle Anzahl
von Parametern.
UCC ist ein Beispiel für eine Methode zur Vorbereitung
eines Probezustands mit einem solchen circuit,
und sie leitet sich von der Coupled-Cluster-Methode
ab,
die den Goldstandard in der
Quantenchemie darstellt.
Die gebräuchlichste Wahl ist der Unitary
Coupled Cluster
Singles and Doubles
ansatz oder kurz UCCSD.
Da UCCSD durch die spezifische elektronische
Konfiguration eines Problems motiviert ist,
müssen wir sicherstellen, dass wir einen Referenzzustand haben,
der das System korrekt widerspiegelt.
Das ist der Hartree-Fock-Zustand.
Der UCCSD-ansatz liefert in der Regel
eine gute Näherung des Grundzustands,
da er einfache und doppelte
Elektronenanregungen in einem Molekül erfasst.
Die Anzahl der Parameter in UCCSD skaliert
quadratisch mit der Anzahl
der Spin-Orbitale.
UCCSD lässt sich sehr gut
auf ein Problem zuschneiden,
aber leider führt die quadratische Skalierung
trotzdem zu sehr tiefen circuits,
die für aktuelle Quantencomputer
schwierig sind.
Deshalb haben IBM-Forscher einen
heuristischeren Ansatz vorgeschlagen,
bei dem man eine Variationsform
auf die zugrundeliegende Hardware zuschneiden kann,
was zu einem effizient
ausführbaren circuit führt.
Das heißt, Probezustände werden durch
Quantum-gates parametrisiert
und sind an das verfügbare
physische Gerät angepasst.
Das ist ein sehr heuristischer Ansatz,
der hardwarefreundlich ist.
Basierend auf diesen Beispielen wollen wir uns das
Spektrum der Möglichkeiten ansehen,
die wir haben, um unsere
Variationsform auszudrücken.
Viele davon sind bereits in Qiskit
implementiert,
also empfehle ich dir, selbst auszuprobieren,
welche am besten für das Problem geeignet ist,
das du lösen möchtest.
Wenn wir uns den Graphen ansehen, haben wir
auf der einen Seite die sehr heuristischen
Variationsformen.
Die Problemspezifität ist gering, aber
sie sind so konzipiert, dass sie auf
echter Hardware implementiert werden können.
Sie sind auch sehr ausdrucksstark,
in dem Sinne,
dass man damit viele
Quantenzustände ausdrücken kann.
Ein Problem, das jedoch in der späteren
Phase der klassischen Optimierung
auftreten kann, ist das Auftreten
des sogenannten Barren Plateau,
das wir im nächsten Modul besprechen werden.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir den
stark problemspezifischen Unitary
Coupled Cluster, der in der klassischen Chemie
hervorragend funktioniert, aber
aufgrund großer circuit-Tiefen schwierig auf
Quantenhardware zu implementieren ist.
Im Allgemeinen können Berechnungen
erfolgreicher sein, wenn du
zunächst einen Referenzzustand und
einen anfänglichen Parametersatz wählst,
die einen ansatz-Zustand nahe
am Grundzustand erzeugen.
Und zweitens unnötige Parameter vermeidest.
Diese führen entweder zu einer
größeren circuit-Tiefe ohne Mehrwert
oder zu einem größeren Parameterraum,
der durchsucht werden muss und zu Plateaus
in der klassischen Optimierung führt.
Welche Parameter notwendig sind, ist eine
problemspezifische Frage,
die sorgfältiges Nachdenken erfordert.
Lass uns darüber sprechen, wo unser Ehrengast,
der Hamiltonian, in all dem versteckt ist.
Wie wir im vorherigen Abschnitt gelernt haben,
wird der Hamiltonian nach dem qubit-
Mapping als Summe von
gewichteten Strings von Pauli-Operatoren dargestellt.
Letztendlich möchten wir jedoch
den Erwartungswert
unseres Hamiltonians auf dem ansatz-Zustand
auswerten, der von der Variationsform erzeugt wird.
Glücklicherweise ist die Quantenmechanik
schön und linear,
und das werden wir nutzen,
um den Erwartungswert zu erhalten.
So funktioniert es.
Wir wissen, dass der Hamiltonian eine gewichtete
Summe von Paulis ist.
Aufgrund der Linearität
ist der Erwartungswert der Summe
gleich der Summe der Erwartungswerte
jedes Pauli-Strings.
Das ist toll, denn wie du bereits weißt,
ist das Messen in der Pauli-Basis
so einfach wie eine Rotation
der Standardmessbasis.
Anstatt den Erwartungswert auf diesem riesigen
Hamiltonian zu messen, der als Summe dargestellt ist,
werten wir zunächst die Erwartungswerte
der einzelnen Terme aus
und summieren am Ende
mit den entsprechenden Gewichten.
Deshalb sieht man in vielen Ressourcen
nach dem ansatz nur
einzelne qubit-Rotationen.
Das ist es, was den Hamiltonian
in jeder Ausführung des circuits implementiert.
Im nächsten Video
erkunden wir, was während
des klassischen Optimierungsschritts passiert.
Bis dann!